.
SERIOUSLY, THIS AFFECTS
EVERYBODY.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
>> Harris: DR. MARC SIEGEL IS
IN FOCUS NOW.
DOCTOR OF MEDICINE AND
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN TOGETHER
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC CALLING BALLS AND
STRIKES.
CALL THIS ONE.
>> HARRIS, I DON'T LIKE HOW
POLITICAL THIS IS.
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT IT FROM
MARK MEREDITH.
ALL THIS WARRING ABOUT
GOVERNORS.
IT'S NOT A LEGAL OR POLITICAL
STORY.
IT'S A MEDICAL STORY.
THE VACCINE PROTECTS YOU FROM
SEVERE DISEASE AND TO SOME
EXTENT PREVENTS OTHERS FROM IT
SPREADING TO YOU.
HERE IS WHY THE -- THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING THAT
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE ARE LEPERS.
WATCH OUT FOR THEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO INFECT YOU.
IT IS LEAVING OUT THE FACT THAT
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED, HARRIS,
YOU ARE ALMOST DEFINITELY NO
MATTER WHO YOU COME IN CONTACT
WITH ARE NOT GOING TO END UP IN
THE HOSPITAL OR END UP DYING OR
GET SEVERE DISEASE.
CALLING IT A PANDEMIC OF THE
UNVACCINATED ISN'T ACCURATE
BECAUSE VACCINES PROTECT YOU.
AND IT IS PLAYING TO PEOPLE'S
-- WHEN IT COMES TO LARGE
BUSINESSES I WOULD THINK LARGE
BUSINESSES WOULD COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION ON THEIR OWN AND
MANY HAVE SAYING WE DON'T WANT
OUR EMPLOYEES TO BE
UNVACCINATED.
WE WILL OFFER THAT OPTION WHERE
YOU CAN TEST OUT BUT WE REALLY
WANT TO TRY TO GET EVERYBODY
VACCINATED TO PROTECT OUR
BUSINESS.
SO OUR BUSINESS DOESN'T HAVE TO
CLOSE.
SO THAT IT DOESN'T -- WE DON'T
LOSE OUR WORKFORCE.
I THINK IT'S A PRIVATE SECTOR
ISSUE AND I DON'T THINK
GOVERNORS SHOULD BE  INVOLVED.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT OR
GOVERNORS SHOULD BE INVOLVED.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO GET
PEOPLE VACCINATED BY SHAMING
PEOPLE.
>> Harris: LAST I CHECKED JOE
BIDEN HAS NEVER BEEN A DOCTOR
NOR WOULD HE BE ONE.
WHEN HE SAYS HE IS RUNNING OUT
OF PATIENCE, IMAGINE HOW SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE REST OF
AMERICA FEEL ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC, WHETHER YOU ARE A
VACCINATED OR NOT.
WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF PATIENCE.
WE WANT FREEDOM AND FREEDOM
FROM THE VIRUS.
NOT ONLY IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
IMPOSING PERSONAL MEDICAL
DECISIONS ON THE PUBLIC HE IS
ALSO, DR. SIEGEL, TELLING
PARENTS HOW TO PARENT THEIR OWN
CHILDREN.
>> President Biden: FOR ANY
PARENT IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
LOW THE RISK OF ANY ILLNESS OR
ACCIDENT IS WHEN IT COMES TO
YOUR CHILD OR GRANDCHILD, TRUST
ME, I KNOW.
SO LET ME SPEAK TO YOU DIRECTLY.
THE SAFEST THING FOR YOUR CHILD
12 AND OVER IS TO GET THEM
VACCINATED.
THEY GET VACCINATED FOR A LOT
OF THINGS.
THAT'S IT.
GET THEM VACCINATED.
>> Harris: TRUST ME, HE SAYS.
DR. SIEGEL?
>> I ALSO DIDN'T LIKE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TALKED DOWN TO
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS IN THE
UNITED STATES LIKE ME AND URGED
US TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
OUR PATIENTS.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS
AND WE DON'T NEED TO HEAR IT
FROM A POLITICIAN OR A
PRESIDENT.
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT.
WE GO OVER IT  WITH OUR PATIENT.
PLENTY OF MINORITY GROUPS ARE
AFRAID TO GET VACCINATED.
THEY NEVER TRUSTED THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT AND CERTAINLY NOT
THE GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT IS PUTTING IT ALL
INTO ONE GROUP LIKE IT IS ALL
REPUBLICANS.
NOT THE CASE.
AND HE DOESN'T NEED TO TALK
DOWN TO DOCTORS OR TO PARENTS
OR CHILDREN.
ONE MORE THING.
THE WAY TO ADDRESS THE SCHOOL
ISSUE.
HE WAS VERY LIGHT ON THIS.
HE NEEDS TO GET IT SO THAT KIDS
CAN TEST AT HOME BEFORE THEY GO
TO SCHOOL.
WE NEED FREE RAPID TESTING IN
EVERY HOUSEHOLD SO THAT
CHILDREN CAN BE TESTED BEFORE
THEY GO TO SCHOOL.
THAT WILL KEEP SCHOOLS OPEN.
>> Harris: WHEN WE TRAVEL WITH
OUR CORPORATION, FOX, YOU CAN
GET A LITTLE KIT AND YOU CAN DO
THIS AT HOME.
IT IS NOT DIFFICULT.
IT IS VERY QUICK.
YOU SEND IT OUT IF YOU NEED TO,
DEPENDING ON TYPE OF TEST IT IS.
YOU GET QUICK RESULTS.
YOU CAN DO IT RIGHT THERE IN
YOUR KITCHEN.
DR. SIEGEL QUICKLY, THERE HAS
BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT JOE
BIDEN NOT MANDATING THINGS FOR
HIS OWN STAFF AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S VERY CONCERNING, TOO.
THAT'S THE KIND OF HYPOCRISY
AND CHANGING MESSAGES ALL THE
TIME THAT DOESN'T WORK.
OF COURSE THE WHITE HOUSE NEEDS
TO BE A PLACE WHERE EVERYBODY
IS VACCINATED AND EVERYBODY IS
WEARING MASKS.
YOU CAN'T GET UP AT A PODIUM
AND CRITICIZE OTHER PEOPLE
UNLESS YOU DO IT YOURSELF.
ONE MORE THING ON THIS.
IT IS NOT ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
I WANT ALL HEALTH CARE WORKERS
VACCINATED AND EVERYBODY IN
CONTACT WITH OTHER PEOPLE THAT
COULD SPREAD IT VACCINATED BUT
IT IS NOT LIKE EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THE UNITED STATES
PRESENTS THE SAME RISK AND
THERE WAS NO DIFFERENTIATION
MADE.
TO YOUR POINT, START WITH YOUR
OWN HOUSE.
>> Harris: THERE YOU GO.
DR. SIEGEL, THANK YOU FOR AGAIN
JOINING ME IN FOCUS TO FIGURE
OUT STUFF THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
THOSE WHO WANT US TO DO WHAT
THEY SAY ALL TH